[Music]
on today's show we talked to a dad whose
son is being bullied and he wants to
know how he can partner with the school
to help his son we talked to a woman who
asked the question is my marriage over
and we talk to a woman who is struggling
with her divorce forgiving herself and
moving on and more stay tuned
[Music]
hold me closer time tiny dancer is that
how you sing that song that's not oh i
missed the melody i think
you missed something we'll just leave it
at that
this is the john delony show what's up
hope you're doing well and you are
having a good time dude that's that
scene almost famous makes me cry a
hundred percent of the time every time
and this weekend my son and i were on a
jeez louise weird
bonkers adventure and this song came on
the radio i started getting a little
choked up he's like dad what are you
doing
oh my closet
uh i'm happy to be on the show with you
today on this show we talk about mental
health relationships everything and so
if you want to be on the show give me a
shout at
johnalony.com ask
if you want singing lessons from me
personally
um you can email james directly and he
will set them up you can clearly have an
incredible singer
um i think that the phone's gonna ring
off the hook for that one so or you can
call
1-844-693-3291 you can be on the show
man we are i'm not kind of all over the
place today james kind of all over the
place let's go to zach in slc utah
what's up zack
hey john thanks for having me on the
show you got it man what's going on dude
hey so stop showing my 12 year old son
was uh physically assaulted at school
last week oh that's spot it's brought us
to light some some separate bullying
issues which we've struggled with um
it's helping with your background in
education and mental health that you've
got some tools and wisdom to offer
because mine don't seem to be working oh
man man okay so what happened at school
with the assault do you get in a fist
fight what happened
uh they were just playing basketball
some kids got upset about him shooting
from the side of the key instead of the
back out or the front of it um
he just uh got all the up in his face
and the teacher came and got him and
separated him as they were walking away
my son had turned around and
the teacher the kid bolted from the
teacher came up and cold talked to my
son a couple times okay
i just kind of know where so what
happened to well none of that comes out
of nowhere it may have been out of
nowhere for that situation what what
happened to your son i mean to to your
son what happened to that young man
young man out of school
uh
so
school didn't even call me a kid in the
school called
my son's
mother who were divorced from uh she
called me i went up to the school and
kind of stormed the assistant
principal's office and
got some answers but
basically they
short suspension and
they don't care i insisted that their
they could be moved out of that class um
i don't know if i'm overreacting uh
yeah
you tell me i think that uh
well there's a couple things one i don't
like the fact that your head kid got hit
in the face and the school didn't call
you that's absurd
that's obnoxious and absurd um they're
always talk schools everywhere talking
about parent
participation in the kids life
and that's not just when it comes to
math homework that also means in the
good stuff and the tough stuff
um
clearly this other young man's got stuff
going on is there a possibility and
before i get into it i'm not ever
excusing another kid hitting another kid
in the face okay it's obnoxious it's
stupid it doesn't we solve problems but
it does happen okay
is there a chance that your son
participated in this meaning was he
popping off at the mouth was he mouthing
is there stuff that you can talk to your
kid about or is he a
um
a
is there a is are these consequences of
something that he may have participated
in whether the right consequences or not
are they consequences
or is he victim of a senseless act of
like of teenage bullying here
you know he's
i'm not saying he's perfect or anything
but he's not the kind of kid to go
popping off or
or anything like that um
but he his whole i mean
our entire school exists since we
struggled with people
uh being he's just like a magnet to
being jerked around uh
in fact we changed schools uh the start
of this year because of that hoping for
kind of a fresh start kids that
kind of pegged him as some things and
we're hoping for
a change
and that's i guess that's the underlying
issue is it it's just a theme and i
don't know how to address it
being objective and i know this is hard
because it's your son
um
and here here let me ask let me tell you
where i'm headed here and then
um it's gonna sound like i'm coming
after you and i'm i'm not okay
but when i look at a situation and
there's multiple multiple environments
and multiple
groups of people and there's one common
denominator i'm asking you is there
anything objective that you can say your
son is
this is why
does he have special needs does he
have
fill in the blank is he
contributing like what what is it there
um i experienced that growing up my
son's experienced that growing up and
there are some things that just aren't
fair in the world and there's there's
some idiots out there in the world and
there's some stuff that we were doing
that was contributing to it so
is just looking objectively at your son
from from arm's length
is there anything that he's contributing
to this
you know i
the only thing that comes to mind i
guess the the one thing i kind of
struggle to connect with him is he's
just like super uh extroverted and
uh
different for me in that regard um
he's kind of loud and
i mean like a not an aggressive way but
uh he's just a lot i guess of the day
that i've heard you put up before he
said
so
i know this kid and he is me so yes
if it makes you feel any better he's got
a bright future maybe he too can be a
youtuber someday and uh wow look how
it's working out for me working out for
me
um so here
here's the there's a couple of big metas
here okay number one
i would circle back when you're not um
and it might be now
there is a i'm storming into the
principal's office to find out if my kid
is safe
and it's obnoxious and it's
disrespectful if they didn't call you
both for him
that they're just gonna send him home
with that level of trauma
and without you knowing it that's that's
just bad pedagogy that's a bad um
bad child care
and
that they didn't participate they didn't
bring you along to say hey your kid's
been hurt here are some things that we
want to work on with your family with
their other family everything
that's number one so you have that right
and responsibility and you have that
moment when you charge in
now that that the smoke is cleared on
that incident i would love for you to
circle back with the school counselor
with the school principal and say
what am i missing here this is we've
moved schools there's got to be
something here that my son's
contributing or that
is making it to where other people don't
like him that i want to be able to coach
him on teach him on take that posture
and you may learn some things
they may say yeah your kid actually you
wouldn't ever think it but
um he's pretty handsy he gets real
excited about thing and he's always
bumping into people and putting his
hands on people and for some kids that's
a threat or he talks a lot of trash on
the basketball court or whatever the
thing is and it may be none of this but
here's i'm gonna do my due diligence as
a dad
am i contributing to this in any shape
form professors my son
the second thing is and this is gonna
sound backwards and i don't want all of
the internet warriors to come after me
on this
but your son needs to have some sort of
discipline in his life
preferably through
whether it's taking jiu jitsu classes
whether it's taking some sort of
um he's does he play any sort of after
school sports
well he did boxing for a few years okay
then we got worried about
tbi stuff and so we we
stopped that great so i would transition
him to both of my kids will start jiu
jitsu soon
i'll put it that way this is something
i'm doing in my own house here's why
number one it teaches them
discipline
and it teaches them when to and how to
it also teaches them to identify when a
threat is actually a threat and when
somebody's being a knucklehead
and it teaches them oh this is what
could happen
and i was a hot-headed loudmouth idiot
until i started taking
jiu-jitsu classes until i started
training with a professional mma team
and dude it changed my life and it
changed my life made me infinitely
less of a hot head
i don't even consider getting in fights
anymore not because i can't handle
myself because they're stupid to waste
my time
they're absolute ways to my life right
and if one comes to me i'll be okay you
know what i mean but there's a level of
confidence that it sounds
counterintuitive i don't want to teach
somebody how to fight to avoid fights
there is something about teaching a
young person whether my daughter and my
son are both going to do this
they learn strength they learn
resilience they learn toughness they
learn discipline and they learn how to
walk away
or how to back out of a situation how
they had to go
all right cool man and they laugh and
they know it's not a threat to my ego to
their to their self-esteem whatever
because their ego and self-esteem and
honor are in other places
the third thing is is i would get
really clear about forgiving yourself
with about this because i can hear it on
you
how much
am i wrong
uh
how he's been
through some stuff he's pretty resilient
kid but
his life hasn't been perfect
no but i'm uh you're hanging on to some
stuff
yeah
i'm not sure exactly where where to go
with that but uh
yeah i'm sure there's some stuff i could
i could figure out
the kids getting bullied it's not your
fault man
and i know you don't believe me
you don't i know that
and
your head get kid got hit in the mouth
you asked yourself what should i have
done what could i have done whatever
i'm telling you is man your kid it
sounds like your kid ran into a hot head
when you when you say you experience
bullying in other places back back up
where what other
it brought to light bullying what other
bullying is he experiencing
yeah so he pointed out
that we were leaving the school and he
pointed out a kid and he mentioned that
that could have been a jerk to him asked
for more details and he said you know
he'll walk up through the halls and take
him or punch him or
or what not
and uh
so for example
go ahead go ahead
so earlier in that same class period
that same kid
and in that conversation this was a few
days before he got cold talked by the
basketball player
um
he told me that and i said well you got
to tell someone you got to do something
about it you can't just deal with it
so that period that same kid
uh punched him once he said he stopped
he punched him in the back again did you
need to stop he did it again so he went
and told the teacher
teacher pulled him aside and talked to
him
um
seemed like an insufficient response to
me and it just pisses me off that
a kid gets talked to for
to repeatedly
punching it i don't i just uh yeah yeah
still still out of control have you
talked to the teacher about it
i talked to the principal
yeah
he basically told me that that kid has a
history of things like that and that
they're working with counselors and
and that's it i mean there's nothing to
there's nothing more going on
to distance him from my son or or do
anything like that so what i would
suggest is having a gentle
kind but passionate conversation
in a non-threatening way but let them
know
i will bring legal action upon this
school if my kid gets hit one more time
we have put you on notice that these
particular children are hitting my child
and making my child unsafe at school
if my child's contributing in any way
let me know
if he's talking trash if he's pushing
first if he's bouncing bouncing around
into other people whatever
you let me know
but you are on notice now
and if somebody else hits my child i'm
gonna hold the school liable because
we've told you and you're not doing
anything about it
and you say that in a gentle kind way
and probably what they will say is we
can't continue this conversation anymore
because you've threatened legal action
and you say great
let me talk to the general counsel of
the district
okay i i mean i guess you're right i
guess that's where the guilt comes in
but it just feels like
yeah
yeah and i do i do identify with your
son
saying i i'm telling the adults in my
life the teachers in my life and they're
not doing anything about this
that's a scary place for a child to be
and the children deserve to go to school
and feel
safe okay
and so this is a three-prong
approach here
actually a four-prong approach
how often i'm gonna ask you a hard
question how often do you hug your kid
like daily good keep doing that let him
feel not hear let him feel that you love
him
okay
yeah
the second thing is has he seen any sort
of counseling or anything since the
divorce
yeah a little bit how's that
how's that going
i don't think you got a whole lot from
it okay
maybe you all two go together and say
we're going to commit to healing you've
been through a lot i've been through a
lot we're gonna go together
i don't even know what that looks like
but what i'm trying to say is he needs a
model for taking care of yourself
and he doesn't have that and yeah it
starts with you
the third thing is is get him in some
sort of
jiu jitsu class physical activity class
gymnastics class a class where he can
use his body where he can grow and
develop self-confidence and discipline
and teamwork and learn
oh wow this is how this ends
and that teaches him a thousand ways how
to walk away how to back out how to be
confident how to stand up with a teacher
and say this can't right how did how to
take care of himself and number four be
very direct and intentional with the
school when it comes to your child's
safety
okay
okay
give that a shot man and
how do i have that conversation trying
to dig in and see what what he's doing
without name this is your fault
you have that conversation with the
school and with the teacher
okay
yeah you have that with the school with
the teacher and
a good skilled counselor that the two of
you all are going together
and you tell them i want to i want to
learn how to be the best dad i can and
so we're going to go talk to this
professional and i want to be the best
dad ever and maybe you didn't have the
best dad model for you
or you have done some things or said
something you want to be better at it
and better at it and so you let them
know um hey i want you to come with me
to these to these things i'm gonna i'm
gonna be learning some new things you're
gonna be learning some new things we're
gonna do this together
but you model it for him and a good
counselor would say oh what if we said
this instead of that right so they'll
help with that it's not pointing what
are you doing what are you contributing
to this
um
but i think a good conversation with the
with the principal and the counselor and
his teachers will say this is how we
experience your kid and there's that's
hard because nobody wants to say my
kid's being bullied and it's on me or my
kids contributing to this because it's
never okay to punch a kid in the face
don't hear me say that at all in any
shape form or fashion it's never okay
and
that 12 year old is a child the one that
hit your kid is a child too
and so there's an interaction going on
between children and i want to teach my
son a how to stand up for himself how to
take care of himself how to walk away
with dignity
and
how to not get himself in some of these
situations and if it's happening over
and over and over and over again it
could be your kid's got special needs it
could be your kid is
um got some is just different he's tall
he's short filling the blank and kids
are just ruthless and mean
and that's where they need adults in
their life to step in and say i'm gonna
help keep you safe this is how we treat
each other so we talk and if the school
tells me oh yeah that's just one of our
violent kids we're working with them
not on my kid you're not
absolutely you're
that violent kid isn't going to practice
being less violent on my kid that's the
school's responsibility to lean in and
keep all of their kids safe that kid
included and your kid
it's a mess brother it's a mess we'll be
right back on the dr john dolone's show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
all betterhelp.com we're back
and we're gonna go to jessica in san
antonio jessica are you there now
yes sorry here can you hear me yes i
screwed up the buttons i was hitting all
the wrong buttons
no
you're fine i'm all fired up after that
last call i can't stand it when schools
don't help out kids hey so what's up
um
my question is how do i know if my
marriage is over or if i
just just a light question among friends
yes just very light you know i'll wait
i'll let you pour your wine
[Laughter]
dude i i don't know that wine's gonna
cut it on this one so why are you asking
that question
um i don't really even know where to
start but
i guess i'll start about three years ago
i became a stay-at-home mom i love my
kids like that is i just i love being a
stay-at-home mom everything is good
and me and my husband had a great
marriage before i worked he worked
everything was good
and then as soon as we moved and i
became a stay-at-home mom it was like
everything flipped
and
i just don't know if it's even
i don't even know if i can come back
from some of the things that have
happened the last three years what
happened
rattle them off for me
okay well um
no explanations just rattle them off
okay um he has accused me of being a
mooch and then i'm only after his money
that i need to be a better mother that i
can't handle our kids and that's why i
send them to school not because it's a
state law but i send them to school
because i can't handle my children
um that i can't clean the house good
enough he will not eat any dinner that i
make because i'm not a good enough cook
we haven't had sex in over four or five
months now
um he comes home he won't look at me he
won't talk to me uh i can't even have a
conversation with him
everything i do is not enough i also run
two small businesses and i'm studying to
get my real estate license and that is
not enough for him
i can't do any more and i just i don't
know i'm i'm to the point to where he
told me to leave a few months ago and
i left and i came back after the weekend
and i'm wondering why i even did that
because i just
when is enough enough and are my
feelings even justified because i know
there's so many other marriages out
there that
are far worse than mine you know and
he's not mean to me because he doesn't
even talk to me
you know but he doesn't abuse me doesn't
do anything but at the same time i mean
i want a marriage i want a partner i
want someone to raise my kids with he
does nothing with our children he comes
home
drinks his beer passes out on the couch
and he's done with life and i don't i
don't want that i want someone there i
want a conversation i want someone to be
interested in what me and the kids are
doing i want him to
go to the holidays with us i do all of
that by myself and he stays home and i
want i want to partner and i'm just i'm
tired of trying to figure out if he's
the partner i used to have anymore
i think that was it
[Laughter]
so
that would have been awesome if you'd
exhaled
real big and then you had like a round
two
that would have been incredible
and i still have a round two but
these are the major ones that he took
the roof off and sold the shingles he
burned my car
um yes so
when did he start cheating on you
that's what i'm wondering
i'm asking you you know when did it
start
oh gosh i feel like it has been going
for a really long time and that's i
don't know i do not know because
you know
you know
when did it start uh i feel like it
started when because he moved here
before me and my kids did okay and i
think it started there i think something
happened i don't know if he's still
doing it but something's killing him
inside and
have you talked to him about it
um i've asked him before and
when when i talk to him about stuff like
this it's like i can see his eyes he
shuts down and he'll just tell me i
can't talk about this right now
or i can't deal with this and so that's
kind of how our conversations go
like it's not really
it's
there's no back and forth you know what
i mean
do they happen
do they happen in the in the context of
another fight
no
maybe let me let me put it this way
sometimes and by sometimes i mean almost
always
couples get into arguments
and that turns into the
i think you're cheating on me
and that's when somebody goes i can't
have this conversation now shut down
that's different so the way i like
that's like me lifting weights like i'm
doing squats in my gym
at my house and then my wife comes up
well i'm in the middle of doing squats
and she's like hey by the way i'm going
to throw some kettlebells on your
shoulders and you can do some shoulder
presses too
like i i can't do everything you know
what i mean so
the only way
here your marriage is over let me say
that
yeah what you had is over and you know
that you didn't you didn't need some
idiot podcaster to
to confirm that for you
what you have to let me say this the the
marriage that as you once knew it is
over
the choice you have now is
do you want to rebuild something new and
better and stronger and more awesome
and do you have a partner to do that
building with
or are you going to accept every single
signal he's given you telling you i
don't want to be in relationship with
you anymore
i know
i'm
the thing that's holding me is the kids
i don't
what do you think what do you think
they're experiencing you didn't break up
anything
your husband broke it up i'm thinking
i'm like they don't they don't even know
what a relationship looks like they
don't have their dad because he's never
here and whenever he is offended
and they don't have their mom
let's be clear
you're gone too
yeah you haven't been you for a long
time
and you can say you're not being abused
he's not hitting you i think neglect is
one of the worst evils you can do to
somebody because you're there in body
but you're not there in spirit
yeah and that starves people
at least when you're gone you're off
with your girlfriend or with your other
boyfriend i know where you are
yeah but when you're sitting in front of
me or next to me and you're not present
i don't know where you are it's
disorienting
it's it's
it's i i think it's evil
and so i think neglect is abuse
but that's just me and i'm just a
podcaster so what do i what do i know
and i'll tell you
comparing your marriage to all the other
marriages out there and they've got it
worse that doesn't help anybody don't do
that yeah
if i'm you
i would
back up why did he tell you why'd he
kick you out why'd he tell you to leave
he accused me of stealing money from him
did you
no but i paid the bills
how dare you jessica
gosh well that's what i was like i'm
paying the bills go look at the bank
account i'm not stealing money from you
to go on this lavish shopping spree
how how old is he 36
okay
so the compassionate part of me which
isn't
i always want to try to see the other
side of the situation
he's done something he's doing something
he's something has happened to where he
is no longer the man he once was
yeah
and he has chosen to exit your
relationship but still sleep in the same
bed
oh he don't even sleep in the same bed
we haven't slept in the same bed in
almost four years then why are you
calling me and asking me if your
marriage is over
because i don't know what to do
god almighty at least bring beer over if
you're going to ask me like this
what are you doing
i don't know
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't
i love him i don't want to
oh gosh i don't even know how to
describe it you know and i don't
sometimes don't think you you for sure
know how to describe it you're choosing
not to
i just i don't know if his issues come
from his parents marriage doesn't matter
i know it doesn't matter who cares where
they come from they are how do i even
get through to him like is there even
but i feel like i've tried everything
that i can and now it is the only thing
that's left for me to do is seriously
just pack my crap
and go why doesn't he pack his
it's where you and the kids live
because i feel like i can't tell him to
get out of his house i mean
why are you why are you using that kind
of pronoun language it's y'all's house
y'all are married y'all have kids
y'all pay the bills you have a job he's
got a job
i know i know i
[Music]
i'm just know weak about it
[Music]
i you hear me say this all the time and
it rings differently when i say it
directly to somebody jessica you are
worth more of a life than the one you
are allowing yourself to live
okay you are worth more than that god
help me your kids are worth more than
that your husband's worth more than that
and he has divorced you inside your own
home and he's too much of a coward to do
anything else
you're right on that and he's divorced
you and he's trying to make you the bad
guy and he's willing to outwit you
forever you know why he's got the magic
key beer
yes
tada
well i guess i know
where to go from here
i will never ever tell somebody to get
divorced ever i know you're not
but i just needed i'm never gonna tell
somebody
to
can i ask you a hard question
yes do you not have girlfriends you've
sat down and had this conversation with
yes i do what do they tell you
they tell me pretty much exactly what
you're telling me
so why is it hard like what what's so
terrifying about the next step
i'm gonna have to do it i mean
there's really no return
there's no second guessing on that once
i say it it's done it's out there
and
i hate doing this to my kids
you didn't
you didn't
you get you can't say that you can't
think that
it sounds like you have worked really
hard
to stay married
are you perfect in this probably zero
percent chance you're perfect in this i
know you're not
is that fair
no
yes yes no i don't know
yes
no one is perfect in a marriage
relationship none of us i know
that's what i don't know am i doing
something
is there something that i should be
doing different that
well clearly if you would cook better
and clean the house more and be a better
mom and stop mooching off your husband
well yeah all the stuff would fix it you
see what i'm saying it's insane it's not
yes
so if i'm you here's and you're safe
physically
here is the what i would do
i would ask my you've heard me say this
a thousand times it's like it's like the
the meta solution it solves nothing
but it provides an environment where
solutions can happen
i would
tell my husband we need to have a
truth-telling conversation
and we're going to schedule it for this
saturday
and you will make child care
arrangements
and
you need to talk about the future of
your relationship of your marriage and
of your time together
and
i would tell him this isn't a fight
this is two old friends we just need to
go talk
and
the whole conversation will be a risk
he could not show up
he could say i'm not going i'm not going
to have this conversation i'm not
talking to you
um
and if that's the case then i think you
let him know it's your expectation then
that um if he wants to divorce you he
needs to go ahead and file
yeah
and you can say
um i've worked with a couple recently um
privately that the
one of the spouses said to the other i
will never file
so if you want out you're gonna have to
do it and they did
and i think um that was hard for
everybody
yeah but they'd been backed into a
corner where one person was just really
trying to get the other person to do it
because they didn't want to pull the
trigger and the other person just said
i'm not going to so then finally
but there was just a truth telling
here's the moment we are in
yeah but i would have things written
down
and say we haven't had sex in six months
you tell me i disgust you you don't talk
to me
you tell me i don't cook well you tell
me i'm a mooch you accuse me of stealing
when i pay the electric bill
i get these
every one of your signals says that you
are done with this marriage are you done
with this marriage
he told me that he wasn't
whenever i left last time
he said that he wanted his family back
but
i mean nothing's changed so i think
you get back and say okay nothing has
changed
what does getting your family back mean
and it's going to start with him coming
clean i'd be willing to bet
not a lot of money because i don't have
a lot of money but i'd be willing to bet
he's cheated on you at some point if
he's not already
this whole thing feels like infidelity
just don't know if he had ever come
clean with it i wish he would because i
feel like it would be a huge relief tell
him if he would
tell him can i just text him right now
nope
you cannot text any of this stuff i know
got it
will you let me know how the meeting
goes
i will i promise you i will let me know
how the meeting goes and be prepared for
it to go
terribly
i know it could be a disaster or it can
be two adults
having a really hard conversation and
this can be the breakfast that changes
everything
okay and what i will tell you is i've
had two or three of these in my marriage
and they've so far all been great
the conversations weren't great they
were hard
but we just turned the lights on and
said let's we got to take inventory
because this track doesn't work
okay okay so i'm not telling you it's
over
i'm telling you no i know
he's he's all but left you he's done
yes
he's been done for a while now that's
right
that's right
cool
you're brave you're brave you're brave
no more no more saying i'm doing this to
my kids
this has been done to you and to your
kids and now it's time to stand up and
say i'm worth a better life than this my
kids are worth a better life than this
my husband's worth a better life than
this and we get to choose
are we going to have a good marriage are
we going to choose to not have a good
marriage are we going to choose to not
have a marriage at all
those are all choices
choose-wise be right back on the dr john
de luna show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you it's why i
wrote this small direct and personal
book called redefining anxiety in this
book i discussed what anxiety is what
it's not and how you can get back on the
road of being whole and well listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndalone.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right let's take one more let's go
to chelsea in kansas city missouri
what's up kansas city chelsea how are we
doing
great john how are you cool go chiefs
right
yeah go chiefs they killed it this
weekend though yeah they did pima homes
he's a red raider
that's awesome all right so what's up
so
last year i divorced my best friend
why'd you do that
well
we got married twice this was a second
round we're just much better friends
than we are
married people okay
and that happens sometimes and so i came
to terms with that but
i filed for divorce in january of 2020
after a very hard we were in marriage
counseling all of 2019 and
it got to the point where every council
was like well you just need to change
who you are to me
and i'm like okay so i try and i try and
i try but
nothing i did even to the point of
allowing him to quit his job in february
of 19 to stay home with the kids
it still wasn't enough
so he filed in january of 2020
covet hit in march
so he's home and the kids are home and
i'm still working full-time at home
and you're divorced two months
i'm divorced now yeah our divorce was
finalized in may
um we had also put our house on the
market in january of 2020
and i couldn't live
in that chaos anymore so i moved out in
may the house closed and sold in july
and the kids and i moved to an apartment
and then he had moved in with my parents
at the time because he didn't have a job
now he lives on his own everything's
great but every year around this time
my kids bring up our old house and how
much they miss it and
i can't help but feel like i've
failed them
and just constantly feel like a failure
because i did work so hard
to keep her house
when he quit his job but
kovid really made me realize how much i
missed my kids
and being home with them
and
i wasn't willing to be the only one
working
in the home anymore but now i find
myself
struggling this year
feeling so badly that
what if we could have worked it out even
though we had tried it twice
we're still like
i mean
last christmas we went down to branson
together
as a
group
and we get along really well
but we're just so on different spectrums
as far as hard work goes that
if we set goals we have to stick to them
and he just was never willing to do that
so
so
a home is a metaphor home's not a place
home is a fantasy for y'all
when your kids say they miss the house
they miss the home
they miss
that picture they have
and it doesn't sound like anybody's
grieved the loss
of your marriage of your friendship it
sounds like y'all are still playing
friend you are still playing married-ish
sort of kind of
and nobody has said
this happened
this was devastating this was
heartbroken i missed the house too
i miss being married to my best friend
too
and yet here we are
i started doing that a lot the last
couple months and i'm in a new
relationship now
where
we were having some fights
a few months ago and i'm like i really
think this is on me
because i haven't greased the loss and
so i kind of feel like i'm in limbo
but it's affecting every part of my life
and i've gone to counseling and
everybody's like
well
this is all on him like you just need to
get over it and think better of yourself
it it
he could have been the most evil abusive
angry
awful person
and you still grieve that loss
you grieve the loss of trust in yourself
you grieve the loss of trust in your
marriage you grieve the fact that your
kids don't have a dad present anymore
you grieve all those things
and so the fact that he
is a good human being you just couldn't
you just decided i can't live with him
anymore you gotta you gotta grieve that
it doesn't grieving isn't about whose
fault it was
grieving is simply acknowledging the gap
between what i hoped for and what
actually happened
and you married this guy twice thinking
he was it
and you chose for him not to be
and so you're gonna grieve that gap
it's not about finding fault and blame
and getting over stuff now man
but you're right it will affect every
relationship forward because you don't
trust yourself
anymore you don't trust yourself to
stick out it when you stick it out when
it gets hard you don't trust yourself to
pick right you don't trust yourself you
just don't trust yourself that's what
grief's for
it's making peace with reality
so i guess my big question is how do i
show my kids
in future relationships that a marriage
can work
especially when the question comes up
with
well you and daddy get along but
why couldn't you stay married and how am
i supposed to stay married like how do i
show them what a good relationship and
that when you get married it is for good
better or worse
but it was i don't want to raise them i
know and i don't want to raise them to
think that you can just
quit if it gets hard you just quit and i
that's what i feel like i did
well then the only thing you can do if
you want to teach them that lesson is to
teach them out of your
out of the things that you did wrong
that you feel like you did wrong
see what i'm saying you wanna you want
your kids to have a great marriage show
them what a great marriage looks like
and you're there's not a lot you can
tell them right now because they've
experienced it they've felt it they've
seen it
and so if you get remarried to somebody
they will see what a good marriage looks
like 5 10 15 20 years later from now
oh
this is it
but there's not like gonna be some magic
conversation you have like by the way i
did this and this and this and i feel
like i did it like this that's not how
it really works it really works like
that the kids can't process that how old
are your kids
uh my daughter is seven and my son is
three yeah
i mean
that's when your kids say i really miss
the house and you hold them tight and
you cry you say i miss it too
i really miss it too
and we miss daddy and you say i miss him
too
and then they say well then why don't we
just go why does the daddy just come
back here
and you say cause you know it's funny
they never i was really afraid last year
when we all went on vacation and we had
to go to two separate homes that they
would be like well why can't we all stay
together not even they didn't even
question it they will someday just like
this is the way but maybe the way life
is yeah and you got to remember that
they don't have that back they're just
trying to deal with whatever reality's
put in front of them that's what kids do
that's the beauty of being a kid and
that is the
that's why being a kid is so brutal
because they just deal with the reality
and put in front of them
huge challenges
you you haven't made peace with this
you are still
you haven't owned this
i feel like i've cried about the loss
recently and i'm just
like
wasted enough and i'm in a relationship
now where
now i'm like
we're living as if we are married we
should get married but then i don't want
to rush into a marriage again just
because life
looks like we should be married jesse
chelsea you're still married
you're still married to that dude
you still love that guy you still call
him your best friend
you don't live in the same house with
him you have a separate life than him
but y'all are still two marriage would
be great right now
exactly
you're playing married you want both
sides of this you want to be divorced
and have the freedom to be with other
people and you want to
not have to live with the reality that i
am divorced
i left him because we could he couldn't
keep goals up or he would whatever the
thing the reasons you left him that's a
whole other call
but you have not separated yourself from
that relationship
you have a legal separation
but you're still
you haven't let that go
and you've got no business dragging some
other poor soul into this until you've
let that go
it's like a weird inverted affair kind
of
am i right
i feel like i've i have let it go but i
never did the grieving process you are
right about that
i
know
for a fact i never want to marry him
again
but we're still really good friends
and you can be really good friends but
you need to be best friends with your
new spouse
and when something funny happens or
something sad happens or something great
happens
your first call needs to be to your new
husband
not to your
ex and i don't think you're there yet
it's like somebody died and you still
pick up the phone to call them when
something happens you haven't fully your
body hasn't accepted this is over
that's what i'm saying
i think it's hard with oh it's real hard
it is
but what i'm telling you is even harder
is dealing with kids who are living in
that limbo and they are
this has been a weird summer campy awful
weird
vacationy
thing
i don't know if you've ever been
swimming in the ocean in the middle of
the night
it's both exhilarating and terrifying
because it's just ink black for as far
as you can see and you're bobbing
with the waves and you can see your
friends around you
but it's also you don't know what's
underneath you you know what's above you
you don't know
what's really happening and that's where
your kids are
they deserve the closure you deserve the
closure your ex-husband deserves the
closure
you gotta grieve it you gotta spend a
season where you don't talk to him
except to drop the kids off you gotta
spend a season where you don't call each
other or text each other you have to
spend a season forgiving yourself or
making peace with yourself you've got to
spend a season saying this part of my
life is over
then we will rebuild a new friendship
because we have to co-parent these kids
and we're going to love our kids
whatever he does can't live at your
parents house anymore he needs to go
have his own life
create his own world and if he chooses
to be homeless that's his choice and if
he chooses to not want to work those are
all his choices now
he's an adult male he gets to do that
but you've got to spend some a season
breaking that relationship off and you
haven't done that yet
because you still want to hang on to it
the good parts of it
you got to let it go
you can rebuild it later but right now
you got to let it go
thanks for that call chelsea as we wrap
up today's show
let's see here who picked this song
josh
josh engineer picked the song by need to
breathe the song's called hard love
dang man
seems a little bit on the nose for this
call way to go josh
don't ever screw with the engineers it
goes like this trading punches with the
heart of desire going to blows with your
fear incarnate never gone until it's
stripped away
a part of you has got to die to change
josh dang gina
in the morning you're gone need to
answer and nobody gonna change the
standard it's not enough to just feel
the flame you gotta burn
your old self away
hold on tight a little longer what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger get
back up because it's a hard love you
can't change without a fallout it's
gonna hurt but you don't slow down get
back up because it's a hard
love we're hard loving right here on the
dr john delony show